3 роки тому Україна та Росія припинили авіасполучення між країнами.
Рік тому експерти почали говорити про можливу заборону і залізничного.
У 2018-му Україна на своїх кордонах ввела додаткові заходи безпеки.
Так чи доведе язик до Києва?
Чи як мандрувати із Москви до Києва зараз? Давайте проінспектуємо!
Вирушаємо із російської столиці в українську на автобусі - наразі це найдешевший спосіб.
У будній день в автобусі яблуку ніде впасти. 16 годин їзди для Тараса - вже не випробування, а звичка.
Нововведення на кордоні - тим паче. Попри те, що у нього російський паспорт.
Розумію, що це вимушена необхідність з боку української держави у ситуації, що склалася.
Навіть за наявності суворої візової системи люди дістаються навіть до Лондона!
Тому, від чогось критичного це не врятує. Але від масових проявів - можливо.
Аби потрапити в Україну, громадянам 70 країн, у тому числі і РФ,
тепер потрібно пройти не лише паспортний і митний контроль, але і біометричний:
віддати паспорт на перевірку і здати відбитки пальців.
Воно дозволяє контролювати тих громадян, які відносяться до країн ризику міграційного.
Крім того, ця система допомагає нам контролювати бази даних Інтерполу, тобто, розшукуваних осіб.
У російських державних медіа нову систему вже встигли назвати "некомфортною",
мовляв, лише створює проблеми росіянам.
Утім росіянин Тарас з цим не погоджується:
прикордонники привітні, упередженого ставлення до себе не помітив.
Інша система, але все швидко і нормально.
Ще 4 години - і ми у Києві. Ввечері повертаємося назад у Москву. Той же автобус - той же кордон.
До можливих запитань російських прикордонників готується Олександра - у неї український паспорт.
Білорусь, Росія, Україна завжди дотримувалися угоди про в'їзд лише за міграційною карткою.
Я вважаю, це було дуже зручно. І було б добре, якби так все і лишилося.
На російському КПП "Нові Юрковичі" взагалі особливо не контролюють, кажуть подорожуючі.
Віддав паспорт - і відразу отримав назад зі штампом. Жодної перевірки ручної поклажі чи багажу.
Окрім біометричного контролю, Україна планувала запровадити ще один:
з першого кварталу 2018-го року росіяни мали би в'їжджати в країну лише з дозволу СБУ.
Електронну заявку необхідно подавати за місяць до в'їзду.
Утім, на практиці цей вид контролю поки не працює.
На запитання DW щодо стану впровадження системи електронного запиту,
ані в СБУ, ані в МЗС, ані в прикордонній службі поки не відповіли.
Російські експерти вважають,
що впровадження такого контролю ускладнить перетин кордону не лише для росіян.
Адже Москва не залишить ці дії без відповіді і, швидше за все,
також змінить правила в'їзду для українців.